what a bubble that's my favorite meme of
all time when your girl asked to look
through your phone how did he say that
it's it's got everything it's so [ __ ]
damn dude shannon sharpe dude how about
his face
you couldn't create a face better than
that dude that guy's the man when I was
a kid I used to watch how to shop I'd be
like man that guy's this [ __ ] that guy
would catch every ball like I'm gonna
throw it 50 yards down and you're gonna
catch it even though you're the tight
end we're playing in Dallas Stadium
Shannon Sharpe I'm John Elway by the way
I'm gonna throw a [ __ ] pass all the
way to the Seahawks Stadium you think
you can get shot by the way he's just
saying la la la problem lalala problem
lalala problem lalala problem